what is that I see are different that
the proposal that's all right agree it
does not me I I understood that my
proposals are politically efficient
maybe maybe is the left except my
proposals so we had a very very bad
score at the next elections that's an
awesome problem that night idea is that
it is bencher maybe have named it is
better when politicians are good ideas
and when the doctor
it is better when they know how to
transform values and one Norris after
I've into action taking me to a gun what
is at stake in the real life but I am
able to give strategy or tactical advice
focus a Goodman that would be very bad a
politician in some time please please
and knows what to say the buell
e you
it's not necessary for evil fortune to
have a read a lot of books in sociology
nah know what to say is it and the
petition is able to do to capture a
situation to get yourself so as I plan
writers group is because in my country
we are going to have very important
elections within one year allowed for my
book is why I had before and high up but
proposals will be discussed that and
then maybe we'll be happy that I i know
i know that for political reasons maybe
I had totally wrong because the i will
ever given an internet example for me
it's a mystery what is pelvis can be
reelected the first time okay but did
not know
maybe but now everybody know'd is having
prostitutes are under 80 is paging just
ease and I'll vote for him then what can
I say to the left he time to detail in
life if in a situation like this one
people wrote that are educated people it
is so an unnecessary answer but I prefer
to try resident I was very received by
what you said about religion
because in the in the French defender
and the basics of it is that
just my knee
one
so if you said that religion is
personal choice we just don't need
basically
we don't have
true religion i have also a second were
wrong you said it was very religious
but don't you assume that there is
regarding the specific issues huge gap
within the Google
when I'm able to come
they are still stuck with
very colonial perspective
and then right
so don't you think that people the left
in France in Europe is trying to
advocate respective just from the
National stay there will be just
and your two points are very important
but I will be more extreme than you even
in France or email symptoms into
Krishna's a nation's important is the
idea of college baby is not to say the
nation state does not exist anymore who
never says addressing his name I think
that what I would say is we shall not be
beg good social analysis or good
facility if we only work within the
framework of the nation-state we should
not give to the messenger care of mother
body to be the framework for outward
this is the book and I fully agree with
you to think and this would be a very
important today a politician that would
say the nation state does not exist I
don't take it seriously women he's dead
she did I mean this issue and not only
can be ruled over that in Italian France
and so on your second part you are
totally right and maybe maybe this is a
great great issue
different
vision I would like generally speaking
to avoid a kind of four people sometimes
all three tries it is to say JD's
because they're in Africa or in Asia or
Latin America they cannot behave like we
be a Europe of course our differences
historical differences as you could
happen in Egypt and in
indonesia six months ago many people
used to say o Arabs will never be able
to what they behave exactly that water
pcc one likes a Polish people with
solidarity 30 years ago and they miss
another dart like you and me
and are educated and to use internet
maybe using because I
I will never say always even to an hour
out of the Gaiety no of course it's the
different historical donations the
importance of sedition for me is just
another segment is adding as really for
suspension now your first boat was was
about Lacey game
in France well first of all it's very
it's very interesting you cannot
translate the french were lazy day by
the english word of secularization i
know that many people do that it's not
exactly an in france lazy day which was
an emperors about notion that we use in
order to say in 1905 when the law was
passed we must separate the state and
the churches so this was what was what
was because at that moment Catholicism
was very strong and the cattery together
league people want to do
to exact a political power and today
situation is totally different to desert
problem is no longer separation of
church or churches and sustained to this
approach the contrary how can we give
some route to Islam oh I can use this
word after what I said I how can we
integrate in system the program is not
to say to Islam you must not be part of
the state's project what do we do with
Islam do we say that the Muslim that be
given some room in special Roman
cemeteries Kalamazoo should we say that
at school children should be given
talent who needs of family want for
religious reasons as well so the problem
is is the contrary life she played the
French lace
I'd to do the contrary what you did with
century not separate but include
so this is a new lieutenant and this is
why it's so interesting and easy to sell
a shitty some people said oh we should
call it a debate today for first place i
said i don't know to go something and so
it's a very interesting but we had also
something in which there was his big
fights between the catalyst churches and
so on and the state at that no matter
two possibilities on the lake side some
people but there is a magnet they were a
minority some people said we must finish
with religion we must fight against
religion like Voltaire fuel and also
because in on the program is Matthew
limited space to religion and see where
the peoples are more influential Atlanta
contrary to some unity when today most
people but not everybody that must be
for say something you they say modernity
includes
religion is part of modernity we like it
we don't like it but we cannot do as if
it does not exist and very modern
countries our black because it is a
tradition exists so the program is to
consider molarity not as the contrary of
religion but as some things that maybe
had to leave some place at which place
here start to do at the debate last
question since i meant i was at it not
just one last question
I was wondering how your ideas on
personalized
administration were received by the
french comic excuse the french so she
was body like 19 oblio people like that
has there been any reaction serious
reaction for reception to them or they
not taken seriously or and cannot I need
a personalized public administration
where could we be doing for it will be
the program was a socialist yeah yeah I
don't know exactly tall but I see that I
that this is very interesting and I know
personally Matty to move our first
person in front of her and the title of
my book she gave it to me I wanted to
call it as a third left and she told me
machete don't do that it's a very bad
title because a certain lame you can
understand me teaser of the second leg
of the 70 and two third away of the
liberalism Kaleta motion goes so I I
took a lot with her now feel very busy
but we have a good trade and she likes
to greet you it's a problem even with
somebody that you know personally you
can see the problem is that what they
need
is not so much long analysis tennis
strong formulas for instance
slowly slogans this is what they need so
and went also what they need it
something which I hate sometimes I
receive a telephone call from the
Socialist Party Michelle Martin is going
to Africa would you write two pages to
help to prepare for disco I know what it
would be something funny all around her
we take the two pages pages by me but
two pictures buy tennesippi they will
and they will is a two pitches they will
extract what they call it in for the
disco anymore I don't know yet
translated a reverse of this code
anymore so they suzi when take one
sentence or a world over so for social
scientists two pictures it's the
beginning of an introduction
okay i can try to say something into
patient that I know what will be done
with system so this is the way
politician where because a share to give
the discourse in the girls so it's very
difficult not so many things but I Texas
precise gate okay tell you what happened
in 2001 she at that mom when she was at
the government and she decided to leave
the government one year before
generation and we were very at that time
I we were closer than we are now because
she's going to Vincent so I said that
she told me Michelle I'm living the
government I've been in politics
politics makes you try telling Joran
drive so I need some oxygen would you
organize from your group of easier to
discuss and I did and during many
moments
two weeks we met a small group of 10
people and it was varied and one day she
told us well I have been I am now in
charge of the project of the Socialist
Party and she said would you accept that
the idea that come from his group I use
them to prepare the project yes because
so potentially but I know what will
happen this idea will be y en el
agreement I ran out from the grandeur I
bet it's better than nothing so Jim so
this is housing so the program is how
can we create more and more places
groceries description debasis had more
than a monte school
in me